Ihr habt das große Bienensterben in den letzten
Jahren mitbekommen.
Und das hat echt folgenschwere Auswirkungen.
Kurz und knapp gesagt, werden nämlich mit
den Bienen auch Millionen Menschen sterben,
weil uns Nahrung fehlen wird.
Was tun?
Ein deutsches Forschungsteam macht jetzt Hoffnung,
denn sie haben ein Gegenmittel gegen den größten
Feind der Biene entdeckt: die Varroamilbe.
Wie also das Gegenmittel gegen den Bienen-Parasiten
wirkt und ob sich das das Bienensterben so
doch noch Stoppen lässt - jetzt in Clixoom
Science & Fiction, bei uns gibt es täglich
faszinierende Science-Videos.
Abonniert den Kanal.
Nur dann verpasst ihr nichts. herzlich willkommen!
Dieses Video bekommt ihr, weil ihr Euch das
Thema über die Whats-App Gruppe von Clixoom
Science& Fiction gewünscht habt, herzlich
Dank dafür!
Den Link dazu findet ihr in der Videobeschreibung.
Das Aussterben der Bienen hätte katastrophale
Folgen für die Menschheit: Es gibt Berechnungen
nach denen es durch entsprechende Ausfälle
bei der Ernte zu mehr als 1,4 Millionen Todesfällen
pro Jahr kommen könnte.
Forschungsteams weltweit bleibt vielleicht
nicht mehr viel Zeit, um die Bienen zu retten.
Experten gehen davon aus, dass bereits in
wenigen Jahren einige Bienenarten ausgestorben
sein werden.
Die Gründe: Den Insekten fehlt es an Nahrung;
ihr Lebensraum wurde für die Landwirtschaft
in Beschlag genommen und auch der Einsatz
von Pestiziden gibt ihnen den Rest.
Der größte Feind der Bienen ist aber die
Varroamilbe.
Sie ist tatsächlich in der Lage, innerhalb
von ein bis drei Jahren ein komplettes Bienenvolk
auszurotten.
Und genau deswegen könnte die Entdeckung
der Hohenheimer Wissenschaftlerinnen und Wissenschaftler
ein echter Durchbruch sein.
Nach 25 Jahren Forschung sind sie nun durch
Zufall auf ein Gegenmittel gestoßen.
Es geht um die Chemikalie Lithiumchlorid,
die bislang kurioserweise als Enteisungsmittel
eingesetzt wird.
Die Vorteile sind enorm: Es verursacht weder
Resistenzen noch Rückstände.
Zudem weist das Forschungsteam darauf hin,
dass es wohl sowohl für Bienen als auch für
Menschen unschädlich sei.
Lithiumchlorid kann sehr einfach und preiswert
produziert werden und könnte den Bienen über
das Futter verabreicht werden.
Dazu der Leiter der Landesanstalt für Bienenkunde,
Peter Rosenkranz:” Lithiumchlorid kann man
Bienen in Zuckerwasser aufgelöst füttern.
Bei unseren Versuchen haben bereits geringe
Mengen der Salzlösung ausgereicht, um innerhalb
weniger Tage die auf den Bienen aufsitzenden
Milben abzutöten – ohne Nebenwirkungen
für die Bienen.”
Und das sind alles wirklich extreme Vorteile,
wenn man bedenkt, wie Imker bislang mit befallenen
Bienenstöcken zu verfahren hatten.
Die wirklich aggressiven organischen Säuren
oder chemischen Anti-Milben-Mittel hatten
viele Nebenwirkungen, die jetzt vielleicht
Geschichte sein könnten!
Und Lithiumchlorid ist keineswegs neu; es
wird bereits als Trocknungsmittel und Enteisungsmittel
eingesetzt, denn es handelt sich um ein in
Wasser leicht lösliches Lithium-Salz.
Ärzte verschreiben es Patienten mit Depressionen.
Ein weiterer Vorteil des Wirkstoffs ist seine
Verfügbarkeit: Das Lithiumchlorid-Salz gibt
es in Salzseen und -laugen, genauso wie in
Heilquellen - und das in erstaunlich hoher
Konzentration.
Nach Schätzungen gibt es weltweit Vorräte
von mehr als 40 Millionen Tonnen.
Das es auch als Mittel gegen die Varroa-Milben
taugt, erkannte das deutsche Forschungsteam
nur durch Zufall.
In ihren Experimenten forschten sie zwar auch
an Anti-Varroa-Mitteln, doch eigentlich wollten
einen weitaus komplexeren Ansatz entwickeln,
um lebenswichtige Gene der Bienen-Parasiten
auszuschalten.
Und ja: Das sogenannte RNA-Interferenz-Verfahren
funktioniert!
Doch zeigte sich während der Experimente
eine deutliche unkomplizierte und preisgünstige
Option, um die Varroa-Milben zu bekämpfen.
Denn in der “Genmischung” war offensichtlich
etwas drin, was den Milben nicht bekam; die
Bienen dabei aber nicht störte.
Zwei Jahre dauerte es dann, auf den Mischungsbestandteil
zu kommen, der dafür veranwortlich war: Lithiumchlorid
eben.
In einer Pressemitteilung der Universität
schreiben die Verantwortlichen, dass bereits
Gespräche mit Unternehmen bezüglich einer
Produktentwicklung und Marktzulassung laufen.
Bis dahin stehen wohl noch einiges Tests an;
beispielsweise zur richtigen Dosierung.
Das Forschungsteam aus Hohenheim warnt ausdrücklich
davor, den Stoff schon jetzt - vor seiner
Zulassung als Tierarzneimittel - anzuwenden.
Dazu Peter Rosenkranz: “Selbstversuche mit
Lithiumchlorid an den eigenen Bienenvölkern
wären zum jetzigen Zeitpunkt fahrlässig
und stellen darüber hinaus einen klaren Verstoß
gegen das Arzneimittelgesetz dar”.
So ist jetzt schon klar, dass Bienenlarven
die Behandlung nicht überleben.
Vorsicht ist also geboten.
Es ist also noch etwas Forschung nötig, damit
ein Mittel gegen die Varoamilbe auf den Markt
kommen kann.
Wir halten euch hier auf dem Laufenden.
Wenn ihr kein Video dazu und auch zu allen
anderen Themen verpassen wollt, dann abonniert
Clixoom auch auf englisch.
Denn auch da gibt es immer wieder Videopremieren.
Dafür einfach hier draufklicken.
Und hier geht es weiter mit: Nanobots become
reality - robots in your own body!
- Bis bald hoffentlich auch auf dem englischen
Kanal.
See you soon, stay tuned!